foreign
George I was not going to talk about
this news story but apparently people
are doing stupid butt things because of
this news story so now we have to talk
about it yes so we we're not a news
network but we wanted to maybe quote
some of the fears that are out there
that have been sparked due to the SB svb
Fallout so for those that don't know
Dave can you do like an explain like I'm
five as to what happened with the
Silicon Valley Bank collapse
yes
okay the Silicon Valley Bank was
collapsed on last week last Thursday I
guess it was
um and uh the reason was pretty simple
number one you need to understand this
about their Bank
the that the vast majority of the
customers in that bank or hedge funds
Venture capitalists and Tech startups
they were not Mom and Pop Granny's CD
was not over at this Bank
that's not who they catered to okay so
to put that in perspective FDIC
insurance for 250 000 covers your up to
250 000 government covers your deposits
in the event of a bank failure right the
typical Bank it covers 75 to 80 percent
of the deposits
in other words somebody some people have
rich people have 500 000 or or eight
hundred thousand dollars or a million
dollars or something in your local bank
but most people are 250 000 and under
this bank was the inverse of that north
of 90 of the deposits are not covered
that means these were all multi-million
dollar customers
sitting in that bank so these were
players
and they got they done got caught okay
this is what happened so this does not
affect your local bank at all it has
almost nothing to do with your local
bank it's a bunch of Silicon Valley Tech
startups and Venture capitalists from
all over the place I mean I know I've
got two friends in Nashville that are
Venture capitalists they had money in
that bank lost money okay and uh but
they play us all right they're not
they're not this is not not Granny's CD
for God's sakes all right so your bank
is safe calm your butt down this has
nothing to do with that and what
happened was typically what banks do the
spank included in order to have a stable
balance sheet a balance sheet that is
very safe to back up the deposits is
they will buy bonds now if you didn't
know bonds have and in the bond interest
rates have an inverse relationship with
bond prices what that means is as
interest rates rise Bond values go down
so they had a whole bunch of bonds that
they bought when interest rates were 1.7
1.8 percent interest rates are currently
about four percent on the bond market
which means their bond portfolio had
gone down in value dramatically
and they had billions in bonds so on
paper they had lost money they lost a
ton of money well then they got scared
and a couple people got spooked and they
start unloading a bunch of those bonds
and then the rumor mill kicks in the
venture capitalist boys come flying in
like they do and started scarfing the
money and they closed the bank that's
what the bank runs they closed but all
the customers so your local bank a is
going to cover the vast majority of
depositors you're fine B there's not a
bunch of players in your local bank
that's not who's dealing in there even
freaking Bank of America which I hate
and I don't know why anybody would do
business with them they're horrible but
even they have almost I mean it's like
40 of their deposits are covered right
and and it's like these guys had it was
all rich people super rich people in
there so it's just number one you
wouldn't have money in a bank so okay so
bond interest rates have gone up Bond
values have gone down consequently
though to the new to the bank crash and
the closing of this bank then they
closed two others just like it because
they were afraid they were good FDIC
gets to pay for all this crap and FDIC
starts shutting it down when they smell
anything looks just like this they shut
two down two more right and took them
over they'll sell off the assets they'll
collect all the money to recoup the
insurance if there's any money left or
the insurance and there won't be then
they will just distribute that to the
people uh the depositors the
stockholders will get up which is
exactly what it was actually it was
trading at 250 issues capitalism when
you screw stuff up you lose your money
that's for those people that are in that
bank that's what happened and they knew
what they were in every one of them knew
what they were in again your
grandmother's CD wasn't over there
you're okay my local bank is fine I've
got deposits in excess of 250 000 in my
local Bank in excess of all the limits
in my local bank I am not worried about
it one iota not a penny Okay but the
great news is the bond market freaked
out because they kind of caused this
with the interest rates going up and
bond interest rates dropped bond prices
went up
Translation your mortgage rates are
cheaper today than they were this time
last week if you were going to get a
mortgage in the next month or so and get
a house run to your mortgage company
before all the dust settles on this this
is a great time to get a mortgage go to
Churchill Mortgage today and lock in
your mortgage today
because this is an anomaly it may settle
back up by two weeks from now all right
but it dropped a quarter to a half
depending on what kind of mortgage
you're looking at because bond interest
rates went down bond prices went up
because these dupers were flooding the
market with their bonds and the bond
people went oh look at us we support all
the local banks because almost every
local bank everywhere buys bonds to put
on their balance sheet to quote
stabilize their balance sheet it only
stabilizes their balance sheet which is
the great joke about the bond market if
the interest rates are stable but when
interest rates go up from two to five
then guess what your bond prices go down
and then everyone shows up that Bond you
bought that was so stable now is worth
less because you were betting on an
interest rate Market to give you a
stability and that was a dumb move so
here we go all that to say get your
mortgage right now go to Churchill
Mortgage today and if you think about
buying a house and you're just kind of
on the fence this is going to be your
month baby this is going to be the time
to jump in jump online get you a you
know get a smart get a an ELP with real
estate whatever it is you got to do here
this is the time and don't and people
are going and buying gold George banks
are gonna fast
it's like they live in the wild wild
west or something you don't know how the
FDIC Insurance works the entire federal
government would have to fail for you to
not get your money out of your bank
when you have less than 250 000 in your
bank
quit acting like you're don't Cash Out
conspiracy carries Investments
everything on the internet's true
Abraham Lincoln said that I mean come on
guys you believe every conspiracy theory
out there these banks are not on the
wire they're not about to collapse it's
going to be like 2008. 2008 was not a
banking collapse it wasn't what happened
you may need to turn off the news it's
not good for somebody at least a week or
two just it's not good for some of you
you really react poorly to the wrong
information this is the Ramsay show